hello and welcome to 0 plane grandmaster
arc or rak Oh akshai why I cannot
pronounce that Cora ok and yep d for
this yeah couple of deadlines against
this is surprising to just place Bishop
g2 yeah I can keep the porn here with e5
I think I should do it it's the
principle reply kind of questionable
that this is enough compensation to be
honest ok so we should be six or deform
maybe t4 okay it is not enough
compensation that's pretty clear but
still not um lost or anything for wide
what what is the point okay I understand
if i take he goes 95 yeah okay what one
issue is i can just do this and not sure
that this helped white it takes you
three ninety-five this is very likely
dangerous i mean i've played a couple of
pawn moves to win the material in the
first place so what is this night before
and white resides or is that point we'll
see we'll see okay there is a point I'm
not sure if it is a it means enough and
it's same enough of a point but might be
I mean my development isn't great Bishop
here or yeah i guess like new bishop
e-cigs s check on b5
so what now Queen to be six to get stuff
traded
he does straight ok ok I'm I'm losing my
porn see a couple of points
ok dt8 I guess coffee is got one pawn I
probably would get a second somehow ok
hmm okay um what to do here if I unpin I
can take those check so King d750 595
should work here ok now i can play the
intermediate check if I like if i take
with the night i can take this take with
the night i can check me there hmm ok i
can also take the rook King c6 special
da takes f 2 context Bishop c5 check
king was Luke 28 hope to you one is a
pin the dough should should win right
come on
the wiki game is really one of the
wackiest games in recent time and little
bit afraid of the pinning of the pins
you know Josh up da to know is playing
this ok can take jack is here and he's
got before can you believe that
so I cannot take so any okay i mean it's
it's a good it's a good position so it
still I'm still amazing okay I think I'm
go here so a chick take their take them
now that's pretty good maybe can take b6
I would be very wacky it's maybe
possible yeah how likely how lucky can
you be how lucky can you be that is
actually possible if I check king of
three I don't have a way to I can I can
then take sorry I can then take okay
Jack I can check and take the phone okay
it was a little bit too quick there with
cursing cursing my luck g5g formate is
the idea
g4 I can take I do I have something
better therefore may be looking at porn
ending is lost so it's a strong is that
stronger
non-threatening night h40 h2so4 29
seconds this is that still an issue I
can check me here and try to get 2g far
jack still kind of annoying but it will
play age six I just keep this protected
check check I have no time white
presented the game what the game I
already thought for a moment that yes he
takes me six was really saving white ok
probably probably apps board why I
didn't make the best of my chance to see
in many ok on many occasions yeah this
this is really hard hard to believe but
this is something I mean this is not
like white has no compensation here is
weird as it is yeah but he has some some
sort of compensation hear the engine
wants to take f6 and c6 like this this
this would be ADA I mean I have a very
weak bone structure and he's got he's
got a pollen already this is an entirely
clear that happens I mean and for
computer it's probably a good yeah the
engine gives it like a pawn but it's
difficult to play okay this is what he
did rook da it was kind of mandatory
yeah II for I I didn't think it's good
Kingda 7 has also given by the comp this
and now this isn't the best this is the
best okay and then taking okay this is
probably as a bit more precise because
he had this check
and now this is a little more it's a bit
trickier check okay they got that back
the engine wants to go rook e8 let's not
a move ahead on the right down this
check check yeah that's pretty good
young pretty good check get place c6 oh
my god you can play see sexy in this
position this is the problem with my
line here I should do this and like play
this position which is probably just
winning just whether the sea poor chap
he can play c6 oh my god he has this
move yeah now probably look T 2 is
impossible you know it just isn't also
on here like something with that okay
this is still a draw but I have to
otherwise the sea point is promoting so
what do I actually play after the six
the engine wants to play this desperado
and then the King back assesses this as
a draw
I probably am so Jack that is a draw Wow
gent here here I'm winning yeah if he
goes here I will take a 20 g fat i
wasn't sure i think g5 was what's the
main main idea here I get the check ki
square bag yeah this is the this is the
clearest I think to just yeah let him
take it if he wants but yeah I'm winning
the king of porn ending easily check yet
he had time was the biggest issue check
yeah whatever the wacky game but I'm
glad to get a winnin after some bad um
yeah bad games thanks for watching